as the cost of living crisis intensifies
there's likely to be more in the way of
industrial action with inflation quite
so high but let's just have a look back
at the history of strikes going all the
way back uh a century or so this shows
you the number of days lost to strike so
the higher the bars are the more strikes
basically there have been and look 2011
the last year when there were lots of
public sector strikes it's actually not
that high is it nowhere in comparison
with for instance 1970s there's the
winter of discontent 1979 or indeed
looking all the way back to 1926 that
incredibly high bar there that's the
general strike really just unprecedented
level of disruption for the uk economy
back then and consider
what we might be going into now in this
year you're talking about public sector
pay a lot of focus on that and a lot of
focus on whether it's kept track with
private sector pay these bars show you
how much they've increased over the past
22 years or so so going back to the
millennium you can see private sector
public safety both have gone up quite
considerably but here's the thing now
let's just look back to 2010 and it's a
different story so since 2010 private
sector pay up by 4.3 inflation adjusted
public said to pay down by 4.3 inflation
adjusted and that's why a lot of people
are saying there needs to be more given
to public sector workers right now but
the question of course is how much can
the chancellor afford this shows you how
much is spent in total by the public
sector so total public spending just
over a trillion pounds
here is public sector pay pay review
bodies say split up between pay review
bodies and non-pay review bodies and if
you kind of add them both up you get to
about 230 billion pounds so what we're
going to do is we're going to take that
slice 230 billion pounds we'll put that
over there and we'll work out how much
it costs to increase it in line with
inflation so first of all the inflation
that the government thought we were
going to be getting two to three percent
that would cost an extra seven billion
pounds or so but of course inflation is
far higher than that it's running at
about nine percent or expected to be
nine percent this year and if you're
going to write it raise it in line with
that you're talking about 21 billion
pounds and the difference between those
two things it comes out at about 14
billion pounds 14 billion pounds what's
that amount to well if we take that
slice and just put it over there let me
compare it to a couple of things first
of all
it's about the same as cutting income
tax all of the main rates of income tax
by two percent which is precisely what
this government would like to do it
comes to about the same amount raised by
the health and social care levy and you
know how controversial that was so it
just underlines it the chance that's got
some difficult decisions to make in the
next few months is it going to be
inflation uh rises in for the public
sector is it going to be tax cuts it's
going to be a really interesting period
for economic policy